>> Sean: SENATOR, GREAT JOB
YOU'RE DEAD ON ACCURATE AND TOOK
A LOT OF HEAT FOR IT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
THE HORWITZ REPORT FIND
SIGNIFICANT ERRORS AND OMISSIONS
AND CARTER PAGE'S FISA
APPLICATION, 173RD CARTER PAGE
JOINS US NOW.
HOW MANY INTERVIEWS DEAL WITH
YOU, CARTER PAGE?
I PRESSED YOU.
WHEN YOU WENT ABROAD TO RUSSIA
AND THESE PLACES, DID YOU COME
BACK AND WOULD YOU SIT WITH OUR
INTELLIGENT PEOPLE AND GIVE THEM
EVERY KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU KNEW?
YES.
DID YOU WORK FOR THEM?
YOU DODGED AND DUCKED, DIDN'T
YOU.
I SAID TO YOU, YOU FIGURED IT
OUT, YOU WORK FOR ONE OF OUR
AGENCIES.
ALL RIGHT.
I TAKE IT ON MYSELF.
AND THEN I FOUND OUT IT'S EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THAT.
THEN THEY TOTALLY TOOK A PIECE
OF INFORMATION ABOUT YOU,
ALTERED IT, TO SAY THE OPPOSITE.
BASICALLY THAT YOU ARE BETRAYING
YOUR COUNTRY WHEN YOU WERE
HELPING YOUR COUNTRY.
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
>> Sean: AND I PUSHED YOU
HARD.
>> YOU ARE SO FAR AHEAD OF THE
STORY WITH CHAIRMAN GRAHAM,
CONGRESSMAN NUNEZ, CONGRESSMAN
JORDAN, THE TEAM.
THEY UNCOVERED SO MUCH OF THIS.
YOU TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
TRUTH WHILE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WERE BEING TOLD LIE AFTER LIE
AFTER LIE, VERY DEEPLY DOCUMENT
IT THROUGHOUT THIS REPORT TODAY.
IT'S EXTREMELY TROUBLING.
>> Sean: EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU WAS NOT
GIVEN TO THE COURT!
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A MASSIVE
LAWSUIT THAT WILL PAY YOU
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
I DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD.
DO YOU PLAN AND GOING AFTER ALL
THESE PEOPLE THAT DID THIS TO
YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
THERE IS A TEAM, ALWAYS WORKING
ON THIS ON MY OWN FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
I KEPT GETTING DOJ RUN RINGS
AROUND ME.
RIGHT NOW, AS WE SPEAK, WE HAVE
OUR TEAMS OF ATTORNEYS GOING
THROUGH THAT DOCUMENT IN GREAT
DETAIL.
LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING THAT
WITH THE INITIAL THOUGHTS WITH
CHAIRMAN GRAHAM IN THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WITH OUR
INITIAL THOUGHTS AND
PREPARATIONS.
>> Sean: YOU DID WORK FOR OUR
CIA.
YOU PUT YOUR LIFE AT RISK IN
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND YOU OBTAIN
INFORMATION THAT YOU SHARED WITH
THE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE YOU LOVE
THIS COUNTRY.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> YES AND I TYPICALLY DO NOT
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: I GET IT.
I PUSH YOU 400 TIMES AND YOU
WOULDN'T ANSWER IT.
DO YOU FEEL VINDICATED TONIGHT?
DO YOU FEEL VINDICATED?
>> PARTIALLY.
THE WORDS AT SENATOR CRUZ SAID,
THE FIRST STEP, THIS IS THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE.
EVERY PAGE THERE IS TONS OF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WHICH WE
CAN THEN PROVIDE.
I THINK THE COMING LAWSUIT WILL
DEFINITELY HELP GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF ALL THIS.
>> Sean: YOU WERE AN ASSET FOR
A THREE LETTER AGENCY THAT PUT
YOUR LIFE AT RISK, COOPERATED
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES,
AND THEY PERSONALLY TOOK THAT
OUT AND CHANGED IT TO SCREW YOU,
SPY ON YOU, AND TAKE YOUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES AWAY.
SAD DAY.
>> AGAIN, DIRECTOR RAY FINISHED
HIS LETTER BY SAYING PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AGAINST THREATS
AND UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS THE
ABSOLUTE OPPOSITE.
I HAD TONS OF DEATH THREATS
RELATED TO THESE FALSE MEDIA
REPORTS, WHICH WERE ALSO
CLEANING UP --
>> Sean: WELCOME TO MY WORLD.
CARTER PAGE, I'M GLAD YOU ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF GETTING A GOOD